Hoping to get your pearly whites brighter?
Try radioactive toothpaste!
Is that a sad, boring piece of toast?
Spread on some radium butter for a tasty treat.
Looking worn out?
Don’t forget to treat your skin with radium
cosmetics, for that bright, youthful look.
Considering what we now know about the dangers
of radiation, these products seem preposterous.
But they were real.
In the early 20th century, the harmful effects
of radiation exposure weren’t fully known
until a group of women in New Jersey paid
a fatal price for us to find out.
So, what is radium anyway?
Well, radium is a chemical element that was
discovered by Marie and Pierre Curie in 1898.
It’s found in uranium ore and is formed
when uranium and thorium break down.
It’s highly radioactive, which means it
gives off energy called radiation.
And that radioactivity is actually useful
in treating cancers, which is exactly what
radium was used for shortly after its isolation.
In addition to all of that, it also gives
off a pretty cool faint, blue glow.
Now, at the beginning of the 20th century,
the mystical healing properties and glow of
radium were being used by advertisers to sell
a range of products from food to cosmetics.
It was like the early 1900’s version of
kale, except instead of being a leafy green,
its horrifically deadly radiation salts.
Sometimes this was just a clever marketing
ploy, but certain products, like the drink
Radithor, actually contained small amounts
of the chemical element.
The elixir was famously used by celebrity
golf champion Eben Byers, who later died from
radiation poisoning.
But it wasn’t radium’s medicinal uses
that led to the exposure of it dangerous side
effects.
It was its use in glow-in-the dark paint.
In Orange, New Jersey, the United States Radium
Corporation used a radioluminescent paint
called “Undark” to illuminate the dials
on watches used by the military.
The women working in the factory who painted
the watches were instructed to use their lips
to fashion their brushes to a fine point.
And while their clothes and hair would glow
from the radiation exposure, they were all
assured it was safe.
But then, the eventually nicknamed “Radium
Girls” started to become gravely ill.
Their teeth fell out, their bones broke, their
jaws actually fell apart.
It’s really a horrific part to this story
that we can’t fully get into here.Now, there
are articles online and a few books you can
check out if you want to know just how much
these women suffered.
And we think you should, but be advised, it
is not for the faint of heart.
At first, the miraculous radium wasn’t the
suspected culprit for all of this.
But, in 1925, a medical examiner made the
shocking discovery: the radium that they were
putting on their hair, clothes, skin and lips
had been absorbed into the women’s bones.
Radium, as it turns out, is easily mistaken
for calcium by the human body.
And once it’s absorbed, the radium blasts
the bones with alpha rays, resulting in bone
damage, cell mutation and cancer.
Some of the workers sued the U.S. Radium Corporation,
but their employer fought back, blaming the
women’s worsening health conditions on syphilis.
The women settled their case out of court,
receiving a lifetime annuity and medical benefits.
Within a decade, they had all died.
But the Radium Girls story continued after
their court case.
The ruling set the precedent that workers
could sue employers based on damages for on-the-job
abuse.
And their story led to further investigation
into the adverse effects of radiation.
Today we use radiation in a lot of different
ways, from x-rays to treating cancer.
We better understand radiation and its risks,
and there are several laws in place to protect
us from the dangers of radiation.
Unfortunately, it took a tragic event for
someone to stop and take a look at the possible
dangerous effects of radioactive material
on the human body.
Want to know more about medical history?
Well check out this video I did about what
it was like to get the very first vaccine.
Don't forget to subscribe and make sure you
come back for more Seeker videos.